let's bring it out lighter Major League
Baseball Network analyst and somehow he
looks younger and younger every time I
see him Danny just got back from
Barbados I know I was bringing over his
coffee look at this guy I was walking
somewhere and somebody I think my kid
said I walk like an old man I don't know
what that is well you look like a young
man but you walk like an old man I got a
fake hip you fake him Yeah right it's
good to see you oh you look cuz I go
through the the TSA and my wife's there
my kids and I oh and I just I go because
you can't go oh so that's yeah that's
the sign well I say I have a hip and
then my wife then proceeds to say of
course you have a hip you got to hit
yeah just one happens to be fake or
replaced I have artificial hip that's it
so that's why I look like a old man well
no but you look good you look good thank
you daddy Major League Baseball will air
Game one of the twins and Yankees
tomorrow at 7:00 p.m. and then Game
three between the Astros and rays you
can watch al on MLB tonight throughout
the postseason MLB tonight of course
stole our Emmy our Sports Emmy that was
a year ago we did yeah from us Oh from
you guys yeah sorry
no no I'm sorry you can celebrate 2018
in 99 Show or The Daily Show do show
yeah yeah will you guys do a great job
no just because I'm sitting here we lost
out this is fun right here we lost out
twice back-to-back years yeah and all
what they do and you know stuff it's
hard man where do you go forgets the
Olympics you know everything we look I
got the Olympics what do you what do you
I don't know what you're talking about
that I'm talking about when you compete
with all the shows and we've always
viewed the MLB Network as a little
engine that good and we have like seven
of the Emmys for the nightly show oh
great I'm happy for you got a couple of
World Series rings anything else you
want to bring up al got a beautiful wife
thank you God you know
blessed and lucky son is pitching at
Vanderbilt yes ma'am
anything else rub it in I was listening
to your football picks and I'm in a
fantasy league but I don't want to go
there cuz Lube araceli with the MLB
Network we'll get mad we got to talk
about the division series we do we do
yeah although last time you were with us
didn't we try to cold-call Bruce
Springsteen we did yeah that didn't go
well no it did matter of fact I think he
purposely change his number it's true I
know he's calling me again I know I felt
bad because I'm just like oh you know
who do you got in your phone that might
improve I got Springsteen and then I go
alright let's call it yeah there you go
okay and I felt so bad after that
because Springsteen didn't pick up no of
course man I was wondering if you ever
heard back from the ring sting no all
right again I don't want to deviate too
far but oh but over the years the first
time that I ever met Bruce was Don
Mattingly when I was his teammate in
1988 the tunnel Love Tour he invited me
Donny did as part of his guest that he
got tickets through Bruce me Pagla ruler
and Righetti yeah and we go over here to
the garden I meet Bruce I tell him about
the Jersey Shore Central Regional
freehold high school Asbury Park the
usual you know trying to hook line and
pull him in yeah he was very nice
Terry McGovern was his guy who has
passed and from that point on he was
always so very nice to me but how did
you get your Springsteen's number so
after the 2000 World Series I used to
play Bruce you know you know getting up
or before the game as my as my pregame
song and during the 2000 World Series
against the Yankees at Shea Stadium the
Mets brought in like mega-mega speakers
and it was very loud so you come in from
from a commercial break and you could
hear the Bruce
so Bruce got to me and he left me a
message after the World Series invited
me to a Halloween party down at his what
he calls the barn down in Monmouth
County and went to a you know family
Halloween party with him and just over
the years just you know criss cross in
different venues but not anymore not but
you know what I always felt weird about
like reaching out
not that guy so even though people are
very nice and they'll offer you yeah hey
give me a call yeah I feel like it's a
gratuitous you know if you just said to
me after the show give me a call I know
you really don't want me to call you
that's true but it's like a nice thing
yeah you know yeah yeah and we should
get together we're never gonna get no no
no they stay in touch
how would you handle if you were the
pitcher if you were hater and you're
right fielder makes that error and cost
you like what what role if any does the
pitcher play in a situation like that
with Grisham Oh after the yeah no I mean
what do you say you don't you might go
up to him and and give him a hug girl
hey man you know who the heck is trying
to do that to Buddha ball and it wasn't
even booting ball cuz I don't know if
you guys shows a bad angle well it was
it was it was an aggressive angle but
when it hit it checked like a like an
English cue ball and and ricocheted to
his right to the left about five feet
and I think his intention as being a
young aggressive player is to I got to
get this ball and maybe I can you know
at least keep it you know tied if it
maybe in his brain the guy from second
won't score yeah so yeah it was it was
an aggressive careless play that cost
them have you ever had to console a
player like I you know I think it's so
obvious especially at the major-league
level to where you guys are getting paid
they know what their job is there's an
awful lot of people watching the last
thing they need is to see the pitcher
throw his hands up in the air and do
that or to make excuses as to why you
did poorly nobody cares
your wife doesn't care after a game if
there was the what-ifs so oh you've
never had that moment where you come
home and you just gave up you know gave
it up and your wife doesn't say hey how
you doing hon or I am so sorry or no she
figured out over the air sit you know
why if it was a bad game what is the
last thing you want is your wife to be
like Jay was out really you never
brought losses home
not to not as emotional as you were on
them I know like I don't I don't know
how I wouldn't do that it's the it's the
it's the 14 beers in the locker who had
the best clubhouse when you were playing
like nice yeah because I know the work
the Mets had a terrible clubhouse but
see was our terrible Clubhouse so like I
grew up a Mets fan so go in the Shea
Stadium as a fan and then eventually as
a visiting player and then I get traded
late in my career to the mat so I was
yeah but yeah it was old and but you
know what I'll tell you this Dan I think
with with these club houses that are
that are made the way they are now I
think they're so behemoth you get lost
you barely see your teammates there's
something to be said for the Cova cozy
spot yeah we're all in this together
look at you guys here like if this was
really big like you're kind of we're in
it together but yeah that's loud yeah
but it's New York and we normally don't
acknowledge when you hear sirens you
know what it's funny you say that so I
had an apartment here moved out to the
suburbs and right when you live here
that's just yeah that's just all day
just part of the noise yes what are the
surroundings there so here so I think
the clubhouse is while beautiful and
there's a lot of great amenities III
would almost argue like they're too big
there's too much going on yeah too many
places to hide we're talking a lighter
Major League Baseball Network analyst he
won 162 games in his career did you know
that yeah you didn't know that one well
that one you know you know your er a
summer in the threes 3.8 oh you know
your strikeouts I do because I was to
either 26 or 24 strikeouts short of
2,000 and when I announced my retirement
spring of oh six after the first WBC
immediately one of my brothers called
and said what are you doing you have 25
more 26 26 more strikeouts for 2,000 I'm
like who cares about 2,000 like it's
3,000 Paulie you got al Leiter's career
batting average yeah who wants to guess
my guess at Dan Oh 19 seasons 613 plate
appearances oh so you'd qualify for the
batting title
I'm gonna go 193 Oh what cut that in
half
Oh eight five
Oh point oh eight five one of the worst
hitters that ever played instead an
amazing batter's box and Dan I loved it
I loved getting in there knowing i stunk
and tried hitchers loved it too oh yeah
no I was just I was a strikeout you know
did you ever do anything great how many
strikeouts did I have 290
all right so half the time I didn't
strikeout that's pretty good I think
it's third at the time you struck out
six hundred advance two hundred Chunkin
I got about 45 percent of the time he
yeah did you ever get a hit off anybody
good yeah my first at-bat after so the
in the minor leagues in the American
League you didn't they didn't do
interleague so now if you go into
nationally ballpark they hit yeah right
so the first time I hit was 10 years
after high school in Game four of the
1993 World Series the first pitch I
seized from Roger Mason at the vet I'm
with the Blue Jays and I whack a double
the left field stands
John Kruk who's playing first he
trailers the play and Kruk II you guys
know Crocky oh my god it's not that easy
I'm like I know crikey and I don't know
if he was really having a great series
at that time I know and I'm looking at
my I haven't out of the bat in ten years
he goes oh my god this is it shouldn't
be this way so fast forward that's 93 94
95
Blue Jays 96 my first start which is my
next at-bat first pitch I see from John
Eric's second game of the year after
Kevin Brown through opening day I hit a
base up the middle and from that point
on did you ask for the ball after your
first year no I couldn't do that oh we
couldn't if that was that 15 14 win that
we held yeah or in Philly rain Sarah you
know is long
that was crazy yeah I remember I still
don't know where Joe Carter's home run
landed it landed in the it's in the
bullpen yeah I I was down the left-field
line with Peter Gammons
yeah and and all of a sudden and Gammons
I think said or Dave Campbell you know I
wouldn't be surprised if Joe Carter hit
a home run here and all of a sudden they
were right there yes and then we looked
down and I was like I don't know where
that landed I just know that Joe kept
running around the bases and I went oh
my god you know what
I did anything did we know if Jo got the
ball yes because I went to Joe's house
in the offseason and I I went to Mitch
Williams ranch to talk to him and then I
went to Joe Carter's house in Kansas
City so I did a piece on both of those
guys on what is it like in the offseason
after you gave up a home run to to lose
the World Series and you hit a home run
to win a World Series it was in a drawer
in his kitchen because I go where
where's the ball Joe and Joe goes uh
it's in the kitchen drawer and I go yeah
right now where is it open the door and
he had it like a sharpie written on it
like the homerun ball it wasn't you know
put up in a you know I gotta believe Joe
I would like to know where that where
he's got to have that displayed anywhere
cuz the late Tom cheeks you know touch
them all Joe you'll never hit a bigger
home run which I thought was an amazing
car pretty cool that it's that's that's
100% true
how many walk-off Hans yeah very very
rare World Series yeah but it was in the
kitchen drawer and he pulled it oh he
goes go open the drawer and I went okay
and it rolled out and I go wait that's
it can you stay I want to act you don't
to ask you about some of the matchups
here yes and the pressure that the
Dodgers are under this year do they have
more pressure than anybody else save it
that's a tease out that's what you do
that's called a tease in this business
will continue without Leiter the Major
League Baseball Network analyst and back
after this and the Dan Patrick show
asked a picture of this I saw a video
years ago with Mark Pryor and he was
just getting loose or maybe he was off
day yeah and he was just going like that
and I photos a wet towel but as a normal
towel alright well first of all you're
doing it wrong well I know that right
here
what's the reason so here go put it well
this is too long but okay we're okay
with it the reason is is you want you
want to snap it like a bullwhip and the
reason why you want to snap the end yeah
yeah like feel like you get up
and if this had a if this had a little
purpose of it so to finish you you don't
want to push the ball and you don't want
to decelerate so this allows you to hold
the towel if it was shorter and to snap
and the whole idea is late snap late
finish so you do that when you're
playing I feel yeah but you only do a
few just to get that feel because a lot
of times you get lazy with your arms is
this pregame like when you're yeah
pregame or a side day
some guys go through the routine I used
to use a stick and it was just all about
just trying to trying to feel like I got
out here and then snap and you could
hear why can't you do it without
something in your hand you wouldn't get
the same audio to it oh this actually
creates it and if you if you're if
you're laying with the speed and the
wrist you'll get more of it as opposed
up okay so that's why Mark Pryor and
whoever but you had the call to tell Joe
and then I'll do it because you'll hurt
me but go ahead and throw so it also
good and I want to eat your hand no I
want you to hit head so then you'll get
a pitching coach to get out here because
the whole thing is about extension right
okay so you'll get an alligator artwork
so now I got this out here you're not
gonna hurt the dude with a towel yeah so
now I'm going to really get out there
and finish right yeah we take that to
the beach like all right night just
that's all we had when we had wearing
around yeah I'm sorry I apology
well the Royals had a bad season so good
cause they've been to base before the
gaol lighter for the Major League
Baseball Network former World Series
champ and you had a 1 no-hitter then you
have the first no-hitter in Marlins
history yes is that right all right how
much pressure is on the Dodgers so yeah
I get it
two in a row they'll be the first team
since the Yankees you know three in a
row haven't won this you know to say the
least for Dave Roberts and you know how
it played out starting to feel like the
Atlanta Braves of the 90s here see now
when we bring this up then maybe there's
the gulp feeling of that I I would say
yes there's additional
uh sure because you get there it's so
hard and so precious you look at the
wild card game the other night and now
the Nationals are gonna be playing the
Dodgers oh my god
like the moment you know with as you
alluded to we were Dodger you know if
you're Dave Roberts did you want to see
Milwaukee instead of Washington I would
say yes but I say it reluctantly because
my old teammate Craig Counsell has done
a great job with with the opener and
they've got creative as the Tampa Bay
Rays have done with knowing that the
rotation isn't isn't elite but yet they
have guys that they can do mixing and
matching because that's really what it
comes down to now Dan even as good as
some of these teams are and we're gonna
watch some powerhouse certainly with it
but assuming Scherzer is you know
continues to get better after you know
his little back thing Strasburg coming
in relief is phenomenal the Corbin in
his in his career the last couple years
have been great against the Dodgers when
he was with Arizona well they sit those
lefties too that's a problem that
they've done before Bellinger is better
I mean let's face it let the landscape
of all the division series yeah I think
it's really exciting we have some really
heavy weight hitters on this right I
mean that you mentioned that Astros
certainly the Yankees are right there
front and center the Dodgers as you're
talking about but then I I look at the
Nationals there's there's great
storylines there one Soto is a great
young player I've actually had pregame
for MLB preseason as an NL MVP a special
player I think arguably as far as 3/4
left-right combo
Anthony Rendon is going on the radar
slightly I mean I think with Yelich
getting hurt it may have hurt his
chances Belanger will be right in there
but Rend onus is elite solid certainly
the Yankees high-profile Madison Avenue
team it comes down to pitching though
right if heels like it always comes down
to pitching it should it should and I
think unless your offense is so elite
and your pitching is good enough to win
the seven five games that could happen I
am really intrigued by this this twins
team as well with the Yankees you've got
that number one in home runs number two
and home runs
the twins can mash do they have enough
or is he starting a game one biryeo is
it enough do they have enough to get
through five to get
- a decent bullpen I guess surprisingly
enough because they're not they're not
brand names we haven't even mentioned
the Cardinals they've probably been the
best team in baseball the second half of
the season
you got an unbelievable closer there and
the Cardinals always seemed if it's a
cardinal way of playing baseball
it feels like it's different than any
other team it is true and and I think
really what I look at all the series to
me I think the high profile you know
obviously anytime you have the Yankees
Dodgers and now Astros it has become
elite you have elite players I mean with
the Astros with Verlander and Gerrit
Cole you couldn't get any more front-end
oh by the way they trade for Greinke oh
no and the young players that they have
in Springer and Altuve in Korea's back
like it's an exciting team with really
sat extort players but with the
Cardinals that listen Mike show what you
you mentioned it with the second half I
think you you have to praise
organizations that knew what they needed
to do right the Goldschmidt trade really
emerged Goldschmidt mid-30s home runs
right at 100 RBIs really kind of
solidified what I guess as soon and
needed some help and offensively they
get enough Wainwright I know he's on the
you know on the older side but you know
when you look at what they can get it
Michael listen up it's in the first game
Jack Flaherty is a legit young star with
amazing stuff no I think that Cirie's
gonna be great that here you the same
thing with the Braves dandy they go and
they sign Keuchel he's now pitched in
Game one
Freddy Freeman is a starter [ __ ] as a
star we got a lot of really athletic
star players in these in these days and
series by the way we did some research
you're not the worst hitter in baseball
history now this is a minimum of 500
career but plate appearances same chance
is the worst hitter ever I've heard of
him Ben Sheets bill hands and then Al
Leiter Al Leiter Bill hits and he played
for the Mets bare hands I think he
played pitch for the Cubs are the Cubs
yeah Dean chance was that like chance
and somebody and pray for rain no spawn
and bond insane and pray for respond and
st. chants I thought that was a lingo on
him toe
yeah how much time do we have here
Seaton before I kick out of the curb you
got about a minute a minute a minute
okay who wins the whole thing who wins
the American League who wins tonight so
I'm gonna puree on paper I'm gonna go
with with the odds favorites because
they are the best teams and ease
respectively the Dodgers in the Astros
should be playing the World Series
do I believe that no III could I could
easily see a Braves team sneak through
believe it or not I could see the
Nationals being an amazing surprise
because they have enough you know
certainly the Yankees will rival what
the Astros brain so I've got I wouldn't
be surprised if those any of those four
combinations were to be in the World
Series let's stay in touch you know yeah
let's get together it's good together
let's do lunch yeah you know you look
like Springsteen a little bit really
yeah there's a little bit of Springsteen
in there I guess that's good but except
one knee like 70 70 and you're 53 Stan
yes Springsteen looks younger a lighter
you can see him on MLB MLB tonight
tomorrow tomorrow we got the big game
here we go that's it Bob Costas three
ball to one four more Dan Patrick show
tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR Live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]